Hajj, the Islamic pilgrimage, is the largest annual pilgrimage in the world.
It is a religious duty that Muslims should undertake if they are able...
...at least once in their lives.
It is both a collective undertaking and a deeply personal experience.
One of the philosophies of the Hajj is that of spirituality and unity.
All Muslims perform the same rites...
...and are encouraged to share in a spirit of equality.
All pilgrims are expected to remain in the states of purity and simplicity during the Hajj...
...as much as possible.
This includes wearing simple clothes,...
...which for men, is two pieces of white, unsewn cloth.
Women are not restricted to a specific color,...
...but are also encouraged to wear non-elaborate clothing.
It involves a series of rituals that take place in and around Mecca...
...over a period of five to six days.
Pilgrims perform Tawaf, in which they circle the Kaaba seven times...
...in an anti-clockwise direction.
Muslims believe that the rituals of the Hajj have their origin...
...in the time of the prophet Abraham.
Prophet Muhammad led the Hajj himself in 632, the year of his death.
Saudi Arabia attracts around three million pilgrims...
...every year from across the world for the Hajj.